PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, we're
going to take a look
at first-order linear
differential equations
with constant coefficients.
And specifically, we're going
to use integrating factors
to solve them.
So the equation that we're going
to solve today is x dot plus
k*x equals 1.
And then in part B we're going
to change the right-hand side
to e to the minus 5t.
And then in part C, we're
asked to use the superposition
principle to solve x dot
plus k*x equals 4 plus 7 e
to the minus 5t.
So I'll let you think
about this for a moment,
and I'll come back in a second.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
So I should mention that every
first-order linear differential
equation, whether it has
constant coefficients or not,
can always be solved using
an integrating factor.
However, in this case, we
have a constant coefficient,
which is particularly nice.
And later on in
the course, we're
going to learn some even
better ways, or quicker ways,
to solve linear
differential equations
with constant coefficients.
But for today, we're asked
to use an integrating factor.
So for part A, we have the
equation x dot plus k*x equals
1.
And the first step is to
compute the integrating factor.
So the integrating factor,
which I'll call g of t,
it's always going
to be an exponential
of the integral of the function
that appears in front of x.
So in this case, the
function is just a constant.
It's k.
So we have k*dt, which
gives us e to the k*t.
So once we have the
integrating factor,
we just multiply our
equation through by g of t.
And by construction, what
the integrating factor does
is it lets us combine these
two terms on the left-hand side
into an exact derivative.
So these two terms are
actually the time derivative
of the product x times
the integrating factor e
to the k*t.
And then on the right-hand
side we just have e to the k*t.
So we can just go
ahead and integrate
both sides of the equation.
And when we do that, the
right-hand side becomes
the integral of k*t, which
is 1 over k e to the k*t plus
a constant of integration.
And now, just to isolate x,
I could divide through by e
to the k*t.
And I obtain 1 over k plus a
constant e to the minus k*t.
So here's the
solution to the ODE.
OK, so this concludes part A.
For part B, we have the
equation x dot plus k*x equals e
to the negative 5t.
So if we take a look
at this equation,
the only thing that we've
changed is the right-hand side.
We haven't changed
the left-hand side.
And again, if we compute
the integrating factor,
well, we know that it's the same
integrating factor as in part
A. And the reason is that
the integrating factor only
depends on the left-hand side.
It only depends on
the linear terms.
So I can multiply the
equation through by
the integrating factor again.
And when I do this, I'll
just combine the terms
on the right-hand side.
So this is e to the k*t
times e to the minus 5t.
And again, by construction, the
left-hand side is going to be
the same as in part A, the time
derivative of x times e to k*t.
And now we can go ahead
and integrate both sides.
OK, so if we integrate
this, we end up
getting 1 over k
minus 5, e to the k
minus 5t, plus a constant c.
And if we step back and take
a look at this for a second,
we see that when k equals
5, we have a problem.
Particularly, the
denominator vanishes,
which would give us 1 over 0.
So this equation,
this right-hand side,
actually only holds when
k is not equal to 5.
So this is only valid
for k not equal to five.
So the question is, what
happens when k equals to five?
And in this case, we
would have x e to the k*t,
times the integral of 1 dt,
which would just give us t plus
a constant c.
So in this case, we would
have t e to the minus k*t,
plus c e to the minus k*t.
And this is when
k is equal to 5.
Meanwhile, for k not
equal to 5, well, we
have the solution
worked out already.
So we can just isolate x, and
divide through by e to the k*t.
And we have 1 over k minus
5, e to the minus 5t, plus c,
e to the minus k*t.
And this concludes part B.
So the solution for k equal
to 5 is t, e to the minus k*t,
which would be e
to the minus 5t,
plus a constant c times
e to the minus 5t.
And when k is not equal to
5, we have 1 over k minus 5,
e to the minus 5t, plus
c e to the minus k*t.
So I'd just like to point
out a few things between
the solutions for part A
and for part B. First off,
we note that both part A and
part B share a common solution
of the form constant c
times e to the minus k*t.
So this is a term that appears
in the solution for both part A
and for part B.
The reason is this
can be thought of as
the homogeneous solution
to the differential equation.
This is the term that solves
the differential equation when
the right-hand side is set to 0.
Secondly, in part B, if we
take a look, when k is not
equal to 5, we have the term
which is a constant times
e to the minus 5t.
However, when we have k
equal to 5, what happens
is we have a term which
essentially occurs
from forcing the differential
equation on resonance,
which gives us an extra factor
of t times e to the minus 5t.
And we'll see more about
resonance in the future.
OK, so for part C, we're
asked to use superposition.
To solve the differential
equation x dot plus k*x equals
4 plus 7 e to the minus 5t.
Now if we take a look at
this differential equation,
we already know the solution
when the right-hand side is 1
and when the right-hand
side is e to the minus 5t.
So we've changed the
right-hand side now
so it's 4 times 1 plus 7
times e to the minus 5t.
So what's the total
solution going to be?
Well, it's going to be four
times our solution when
the right-hand side was 1,
plus seven times the solution
when the right-hand side
was e to the minus 5t.
This is one of the beautiful
things about linear equations.
When we add two forcings
to the right-hand side,
our total solution
is just going to be
the sum of the solutions
to the individual terms.
OK.
So what this means
is our solution, x,
is going to be 4
times the solution
when the right-hand side was 1.
And in that case, it was 1 over
k plus c e to the minus k*t,
plus 7 times the solution
when the right-hand side was e
to the minus 5t.
And when k was not equal to 5,
this becomes 1 over k minus 5,
e to the minus 5t, plus
c e to the minus kt.
So if we take a look at
the sum of these two terms,
I'll denote the two
constants as c_1 and c_2.
We actually have 4 times
c_1 plus 7 times c_2.
That's just going to give
us a new constant, c_3.
So in general, this becomes 4
over k plus 1 over k minus 5,
e to the minus 5t, plus a
constant c e to the minus k*t.
So I can just recombine
the 4c e to the minus k*t,
and the 7c e to the minus k*t.
That together just gives
me a new constant, c_3,
times e to the minus k*t.
And this is the solution
when k is not equal to 5.
When k equals to 5, what we do
is we just replace this term
with t e to the minus k*t.
So this is when k
is not equal to 5.
It should be a 7 here.
So I'll just conclude there.
And for summary,
we've taken a look
at a first-order
linear differential
equation with a couple
different right-hand sides.
We've solved them using
an integrating factor.
And then what we've done is
we've used the superposition
principle to solve the same
ODE for a right-hand side which
is the superposition of
multiples of the functions
that we've had in
part A and for part B.
So I'd like to conclude here,
and I'll see you next time.